(upbeat music)
- [Man] Funding for this
program was provided by
the UCLA Office of
Instructional Development.
(dramatic music)
(audience applauding)
- Professor Bristow and
Executive Vice Chancellor Waugh,
thank you very much for
the kind introduction.
I'd like to thank the faculty committee
for giving me the honor and privilege
of presenting this lecture.
Family, friends, colleagues, students,
and those who are interested
in matters of breathing,
I welcome you.
I'm gonna talk to you today
about breathing matters.
And just give you an outline
of what I'm going to say,
I'm going to tell you
a little bit about me
so you understand why a
scholar would be interested in
understanding the basic mechanisms
by which the brain controls breathing.
I'll tell you a little bit
about breathing in general,
just so you understand what
the brain has to work with
in order for us to be able
to ventilate properly.
I'll talk about our discovery of
the principal engine for
breathing that drives the rhythm
that you're all experiencing right now.
I'll then talk about
some of the mechanisms
that my underlie rhythmic generation.
Then I'll talk a little bit about
a discovery of a second engine
that was totally unexpected.
And then I'll talk about
some recent work we've done
about things that are
not normally considered
part of the general aspect of breathing.
One is sighing, which I think
is a rather interesting story.
And the other is about
breathing and emotion.
Now, a little bit about my background.
There we go.
When I went to graduate school,
I was very interested in
studying the physics of space and time.
And that was going to be my thing.
I went to a university that
had a great cosmologist
and I was all set to work on this.
But it was a time in
universities throughout America
that students were very
interested in perception
and I read a lot about perception.
And I realized that the
perception of space and time
was a really interesting problem.
And I got read, and I read about it,
and I went to my physics
department professor and I said,
look, here's the problem
I want to work on.
You have an image, it
goes through your retina,
it goes through this complex process,
and then up in your head pops grandma.
Now, how does this happen?
Well, when I told that to my
advisor, he about had a stroke.
Because he said, this is
an impossible problem.
I can't let you work on
The only way I'm gonna permit
you to work on a problem
is you find something that's solvable.
So I went back and I
spoke to a lot of people,
read quite a bit, and they said, look,
the simplest problem is
if we have a tonic input
and it goes into a
relatively simple circuit
and out comes a rhythm.
And as a physicist, rhythms
were right in my sweet spot.
And what is a behavior that
fits into this category?
It's breathing because we can say,
we have tonic inputs related
to oxygen and carbon dioxide,
and ultimately, we produce
a rhythm for breathing.
I thought this would be
a rather simple problem
I'd solve for my PhD thesis
and then move on to other things.
Well, I'm still doing
it because it turns out,
it's not as simple as we thought.
Now, breathing, to me, is a critical thing
that the brain does.
And my colleagues in Europe,
writing in a manifesto
about why brain research is important
wrote in the second
sentence of their preface,
"It is more than clear to us that
"our brain is extremely important to us.
"It allows us to breathe."
So the first thing they
talk about the brain doing
is breathing.
So breathing is fundamentally important
and it's a fundamental
thing that the brain does.
And of course, breathing, we
see throughout all of culture,
we use metaphors with
respect to breathing,
and I'm gonna give you a
clip from popular culture.
- He's right.
We're all on the same side.
- How can we be?
- We're all breathing.
- So we're all breathing.
And in a way, this is an unusual lecture
because I'm gonna be lecturing you
about something you're doing right now.
It's inexorable, you can't
stop, you'll be doing it.
It's okay if you're
self-conscious about it
because I think it might have
a little bit more valence
to you if you realize
what I'm talking about is something
you're actually doing right now.
Now, I'm gonna intersperse
my talk with this,
which is a signal that I would like you to
take a deep, one deep breath.
And that one deep breath
actually has a purpose.
It'll, if you're getting
a little bit tired,
it'll alert you, it may actually
improve your cognitive function
so what I've just told you might register
a little bit more deeply,
and gets you ready for the next
thing I'm gonna talk about.
So don't be shy when you see this.
Now, why do we breathe?
Well, the principal
reason is we need oxygen
for the metabolism of cells.
And when we metabolize
oxygen, we produce CO2.
We use about 250 milliliters
a minute of oxygen.
And that's about a fistful size of oxygen
that our bodies are using at rest.
But in our body, we only
have 1000 milliliters,
that is, we only have
a four-minute supply.
This means we have to
breathe continuously.
We can't stop.
It's inexorable because we only have
a four-minute supply in our blood.
So we have to breathe continuously.
Now, the byproduct of
this oxidative metabolism
is carbon dioxide.
Carbon dioxide is very
critical in determining
the acid-base balance of the,
our body and cells, the pH.
And we need to exquisitely regulate that
because cells get very
unhappy when the pH gets off.
So we have to exquisitely
control breathing.
Now, at the center of all
this is an organ, the lung.
And the lung expands and contracts,
but the lung itself has
no muscle to do that.
The lung is just like a balloon
and it has to be expanded and contracted
by the muscles around it.
But it's not just one big balloon,
it's a balloon that has
a lot of little balloons.
That is, the air comes
in through your trachea,
this one tube, and it branches,
and it branches, and it
branches, and it branches.
At the end, you have 500 million terminals
with these tiny little spheres.
Each sphere is about one-hundredth
of an inch in diameter.
And that's where the oxygen and CO2
gets into and out of the bloodstream.
500 million of them, but
that's a lot of surface area.
It's about 70 square meters.
Now, what that means, that's about
one-third the size of a tennis court.
So at every breath, you're
expanding and relaxing
this rubber-like membrane
that's a third the size of a tennis court.
In order to do that, mammals
evolved a very special muscle
that is able to do that.
And that muscle is the diaphragm
that sits under the lung
and it pulls down about
three-quarters of an inch
to expand the lung and then
relaxes and the air flows out.
So there's a very special
muscle, the diaphragm,
and we'll talk a little
bit about that later.
Now, breathing starts in utero.
You have to be breathing
the instant you're born,
so in the third trimester
you're starting to
engage in rhythmic activity
and your muscles move,
the lung gets stressed, and it's vital
that it works when you're born.
You breathe all the time,
about 12 times a minute.
You might take 600 million
breaths in a normal lifetime.
So the system has to be extremely robust
and has to be reliable.
And, of course, if you get
arrest without interruption,
without intervention,
excuse me, death results.
This could be natural causes,
it could be opiate overdose,
it could be injury, and,
unfortunately, nerve gasses,
the principal cause of death
is that they stop breathing.
Breathing uses about 7%
of your body metabolism.
We evolved that that's the
minimal amount of energy
that we can expend and still move
the amount of air we need to move.
So breathing is extremely efficient.
Now, in addition to blood gasses,
we use the breathing apparatus
for a lot of other things.
We have reflexes to keep
the airways working,
coughing, sneezing, yawning, gagging.
We have volitional and other behaviors,
my ability to speak, sniffing,
during birth, spitting,
and if you're a rodent,
whisking seems to be
driven by breathing movements.
We have emotional movements
that are driven by breathing.
We laugh, we cry, we sigh,
we can hyperventilate,
we breath hold, we gasp, and
if you're a cat you might purr.
So these are all emotional
breathing movements.
We also know breathing can affect emotion.
Meditative breathing can
affect emotional state,
sense of pain, cognitive function.
And I'll talk about that
at the end of the talk.
And the breathing rhythm, cycle by cycle,
is everywhere throughout your body.
It modulates, your pupil diameter
oscillates with the respiratory cycle.
We don't know why, but it does.
Your reaction time varies
with the respiratory cycle,
boxers and martial artists know this.
And your fear response varies
with the respiratory cycle.
You're more fearful of certain things
during inspiration than expiration.
We don't know why, but
that's just the observation.
Excuse me.
And it's present in
many areas of the brain
and it's probably involved
in a lot of functions
that are necessary for normal
higher function of the brain.
Now, breathing is not always perfect.
Illness or injury can
cause changes of breathing,
which can cause further problems.
So in a variety of
neurodegenerative diseases
like Parkinson's and Alzheimer's and ALS,
commonly referred to as
Lou Gehrig's disease,
these diseases result
in changes in breathing
and that in itself can
cause further damage.
These problems with breathing
are usually happening
during sleep, so they're not noticed,
but severe problems of
breathing during sleep
can affect brain function.
We have what are called
single gene mutations
where a single gene gets mutated.
And we have diseases like
congenital central
hyperventilation syndrome.
There's about 1000 kids
worldwide who have this.
And they have to remember to breathe.
When they fall asleep,
they stop breathing.
So they have to be ventilated at night,
and if they're ventilated at night,
they can grow to healthy adulthood.
Rett syndrome is another disease
that affects about one in 9000
girls under the age of 12.
And they have particularly emotional,
they have emotional problems
related to breathing.
Insults or injuries, strokes,
spinal cord injury will affect breathing.
And these other things are
actually very important.
So sleep apneas affect
about 18 million Americans.
And looking at the
demographics of this audience,
I would say there's a
reasonable fraction of people
who have sleep apnea.
And some of you may be undergoing
CPAP therapy for sleep apnea.
Opiate overdose, I think
the latest number is
70,000 in America died last
year from opiate overdose.
Sudden infant death is the
most prevalent cause of death
in infants under one years of age.
And the terminal event
is they stop breathing.
And we have things like
panic and anxiety disorders,
which are associated with
severe breathlessness.
Now, so we have this beautiful
machine of breathing.
And the question that I
asked a long time ago is,
where is the engine for breathing?
And of course, most of us
would probably look here,
but, in fact, it's back there.
So the engine for breathing was not
exactly where we thought it was.
The history goes back, at
least in Western culture,
to Galen, who noted that gladiators
and animals with high neck injuries
immediately stop breathing,
but if they're injured way below the neck,
they continue to breathe.
So there's something happening
in the area around the neck
that's critical for
generating breathing rhythm.
There's a big gap in the science of this.
And then in the early 1800s,
LeGallois concluded that
the noeud vital, the node of life,
because breathing is associated with life,
so the noeud vital, the vital
node, is in the brainstem.
And I'll talk about where that is.
In 1909, the renowned neuroanatomist
Ramon y Cajal proposed
a circuit for brainstem
control of breathing.
And in 1931, Lord Adrian showed that
you can take the brainstem
out of a goldfish,
put it in a dish, and it still generates
a rhythm of breathing.
So it means that the rhythm
of breathing can be generated
within the nervous system.
You don't need all that
apparatus to generate the rhythm.
So a little bit like the engine of a car.
It works in the car, but
you can take the engine out
and put it on a table, and hook it up,
and the engine will still work.
And that's a great advantage
for if you're trying to
understand how the engine works.
So here we have a human,
you'll see the lungs,
the diaphragm, but I wanna
focus on this part of the brain
and in particular, the
brainstem, which is down here.
And we discovered a region which we call
the preBotzinger Complex
that in humans has
about 5000 neurons.
And this is the engine for breathing.
And I wanna spend a
few minutes telling you
how we discovered this.
So we started out by taking the brainstem
and spinal cord from a newborn rat.
This is a generalized preparation
that have been used by
Japanese investigators.
And when you put it in a dish
and you use a recording electrode,
you can record rhythmic activity
coming out of this
chunk of nervous system.
And that rhythm activity,
if it were connected,
would be driving the respiratory muscles.
So we did a simple experiment.
We said, okay, let's suppose we cut away
parts of the brainstem.
Does the rhythm go away?
So we make one cut, nothing happens,
we make the second cut, nothing happens,
a third cut, nothing happens,
but we make a fourth cut,
the rhythm goes away.
So it says that this region
around that yellow line,
there's something critical going on there.
Then we can do the experiment
going the other direction,
but we have to move the electrode up.
So we move the electrode up
and we still get this rhythmic activity,
but now we can cut away the spinal cord.
Of course, we lose this nerve,
so there's no activity there,
but we still have
activity coming out here.
We make another cut,
we still have activity.
But we make one more cut,
and the activity goes away.
So it says that there's something critical
happening in this region.
So what we did is, we took
a slice through this region.
We just made a cut here and a cut here,
and we put it in a dish, and we asked,
would we see breathing rhythm
in this thin slice of brainstem?
So this is what the slice looks like.
And here we have these glass electrodes
on the hypoglossal nerve.
That's the nerve that would
normally enervate the tongue.
And the tongue has respiratory movements.
And this is a schematic
of what it looks like.
So here's the output
coming out the 12th nerve,
the hypoglossal nerve.
Here's where the neurons
are that come out the nerve.
But what's driving this
are cells in this region.
And we can see that by recording.
So record from the output,
we have rhythmic outputs.
This is in real time.
And if we record from the neuron here,
we can see that neuron
is firing rhythmically.
So this is driving that.
Now, where does the name
preBotzinger come from?
Botzinger is not a famous
German neuroanatomist,
as many people mistakenly think.
The history goes back when we identified
a region in the brainstem.
So this is the brainstem.
We identified a region
indicated by these red dots.
And it had no name in any of the atlases,
the maps of the brain.
And I had presented this work
at a meeting in Stockholm
and had a colleague who had proposed
a different region of the brain
was critical for breathing.
And he got up and he ripped me to shreds.
It was a post-doc, it was
not particularly pleasant.
A year later, we had
another meeting in Germany
and he gets up and he not only
confirms that this exists,
but starts taking credit
for its existence.
And there's a tradition in science
of people naming things after themselves.
I was afraid they were
going to name it after him.
We were at a banquet,
there were about 100 of us,
and I got very nervous they
were gonna name it after him,
so I stood up and I said we should,
if he found this great
area, we should name it.
And I had no idea what to name it.
And the only thing with a
name that was in front of me
was this battle of wine.
(audience laughing)
And I picked up the
bottle of wine and I said,
we should name it after
the bottle of wine,
which we were all drinking.
We were sufficiently
inebriated that it stuck.
Now, it turns out Botzinger,
and we call it the Botzinger Complex,
was not the place generating the rhythm,
but we found another place
indicated in yellow here
that we thought was generating the rhythm.
And because of its proximity
to the Botzinger Complex,
this had no name in the literature,
and because we thought it
was the source of the rhythm,
we named it the preBotzinger Complex.
If you wanna hear the full story,
I had an interview with
the BBC two years ago.
And if you Google Feldman,
BBC, sighs, S-I-G-H-S,
you can listen to the interview
and it tells the story in
sort of all its gory detail.
It's sort of fun to listen to.
So I'm gonna talk about
the preBotzinger Complex.
And of course, we take the slice,
that's the slice I told you about,
and if we look at the slice,
we have high magnification,
you can see these neurons are lighting up.
This is a slice from a
mouse that's been engineered
that whenever there's
activity in the cells,
the cells light up and we can see
the light of them lighting up.
And so you can see they
light up rhythmically.
And in your brainstems right
now, every time you inspire
you have a few thousand cells lighting up
that are ultimately gonna cause
your diaphragm to contract
and then they stop firing
and your diaphragm relaxes.
If we silence about 10% of these neurons
and we can do that by
doing some molecular magic,
if we look at the normal
breathing pattern in an adult rat,
this awake rat, the rat's
breathing, this is one minute,
and now we add a drug that's gonna
just turn off 10% of these neurons
and only that in the whole brain.
It takes a minute or two
for the drug to get around
to where the preBotzinger Complex is.
And then the animal stops breathing.
You get what's called apnea.
It literally stops breathing.
The animal's awake, it stops breathing.
We have to mechanically
ventilate the animal
because it's not breathing.
And after an hour, it
starts breathing again.
So I think this demonstrates
that the preBotzinger Complex
is the engine for normal breathing.
Well, that's a big finding
because now we know where to look.
All right, time to take a deep breath
because we're gonna now move on
to talk about rhythm generation.
Oh, I put the next thing in
for those people who are not scientists
to understand a little bit about science.
As I alluded to earlier
about the Botzinger Complex,
science is not just a group
of smart men and women
getting together and coming to a consensus
simply based on the data.
It's a human endeavor.
And there are many different
descriptions like this,
but this is the one by
Haldane, which I like,
who calls it the four stages of truth.
You propose a new idea.
The first thing that happens is
the colleagues who have a vested
interest in something else
say, this is worthless nonsense.
That happened with the
preBotzinger Complex.
This is an interesting but
perverse point of view.
So they transform a bit, they accept that
the data may be right, but it's perverse.
Then, this is true but quite unimportant.
And then finally, they
said, I always said so.
(audience laughing)
And although it's nice when
they get around to this point,
you then, they position themselves
so they get in front of you
and you wanna get your
full credit for this.
So this happened with
the Botzinger Complex.
The preBotzinger Complex,
it took about 10 years
to win over people.
And it was a big battle
that we had with people
to try and get them to see the data.
Okay, so let's talk
about rhythm generation.
What are the usual suspects?
The most obvious idea
to most of us scientists
is that it's a pacemaker neuron.
So we know the heart is
driven by cells that,
if they were totally isolated,
would generate a rhythm.
They have special properties,
they generate a rhythm,
so why not breathing?
Breathing has to be just
as reliable as the heart.
So you have these neurons
which are called pacemakers.
So pacemaker neurons are
the kernel of breathing
was the idea.
That's a seductive idea that doesn't work.
So this was stuck in the literature
and we found pacemaker neurons
in the preBotzinger Complex,
so that seemed to be
consistent with this idea.
Then we designed an experiment
with Christopher Donegro
where we blocked the pacemaker activity.
So we got rid of the pacemakers.
And the rhythm continued.
So here's the rhythm
under control conditions
and then we get rid of pacemakers
and we still have a rhythm.
The amplitude is down a little bit,
but that's not the point.
The point is that the rhythm persists
in the absence of these pacemaker cells.
So if it's not pacemakers,
maybe it's inhibition.
So here's another favorite idea.
The idea being is that
you start the activity,
the activity grows and
it grows and it grows
and then you reach a trigger point
and then some massive sort of inhibition
sort of slams the door.
And that's how you get the cycle going.
And in the nervous system,
that slamming the door
would be done by inhibition.
And we know inhibition is important.
So here we can excite
preBotzinger inhibitory neurons.
So we just, we engineer the mice
so they have in the inhibitory neurons
a special channel called channelrhodopsin
that when you shine
light, excites the cells.
So when we excite the inhibitory cells,
the animal stops breathing.
So those inhibitory
cells can do something.
The thing is, are they critical
for the breathing rhythm?
So we did another experiment.
So this would be the
control, and this is just
the cartoon to say we have
excitation and inhibition.
And we record, this is in a rat,
and you can see the animal
is breathing quite fine.
This is their breathing effort.
Now we block inhibition.
What happens?
Theory would predict you'd have no rhythm.
But in fact, you do have a rhythm.
It's slower, and the reason it's slower
because some of the things that
inhibition does is regulate the timing,
but it's not critical for
generating the rhythm.
So we have to throw that out.
The rhythm persists and
inhibition is not necessary.
So if it's not pacemakers
and it's not inhibition,
maybe it's bursting.
Now, what do I mean by bursting?
Well, if anyone knows the score
they could probably scream it out,
but you know, if you were
sitting outside Dodgers Stadium,
could you figure out
the rules of baseball?
So you have your mobile
phone in hand and you notice,
every time there's a big
scream from the crowd,
the score goes up.
And you notice this is consistently.
So you form a hypothesis.
The screaming of the crowd is
what's causing the runs to go up.
(audience laughing)
Reasonable hypothesis.
You know, a lot of what we do
with the brain is like that.
We're standing outside the stadium,
trying to figure out
what's going on inside.
Then one day, the Dodgers have a game,
but there's no, the
public is not allowed in.
And you're watching on your cell phone,
standing outside the
stadium, and you notice that
the score keeps incrementing
and there's no crowd.
So you say, the crowd is not necessary
for generating the rhythm.
Doesn't tell you what is,
but it says the crowd is not.
So when we think about breathing,
what's the most noticeable
thing about breathing?
The most obvious thing is
these inspiratory efforts
that you're making every breath.
So something related to
driving that inspiratory effort
must be critical for
generating the rhythm.
So we did an experiment.
And we call this the burst hypothesis.
That is, if we look at the diaphragm,
the diaphragm generates
these inspiratory bursts.
If you look in the preBotzinger Complex,
the preBotzinger Complex is
also generating these bursts
and the causality is the
bursts here drive those bursts.
But we also noticed that
there's some activity
preceding the bursts which we call
the preinspiratory
activity, or the burstlet,
that's not present here.
So we did an experiment.
We recorded from the preBotzinger Complex
and they hypoglossal nerve
in one of these slices.
And we get these bursts of activity
in the hypoglossal nerve,
we get these bursts in the preBotzinger,
and you see that it's one to one.
Every time there's a
burst in the preBotzinger,
it drives a burst in the hypoglossal.
This is consistent with a burst hypothesis
for rhythmogenesis.
Now we do it under conditions
of lower excitability
and we notice that every time there's
a burst in the hypoglossal,
there's a burst in preBotzinger.
So that's consistent of these
bursts driving these bursts.
But if we look more
carefully at the activity
in the preBotzinger Complex,
and what I mean by activity,
this is the sum of all
the activity going on
in all the thousand neurons,
you see these little things
which we call burstlets.
And if you look carefully,
it looks like they're keeping time.
And you can see that more clearly here.
So here are two consecutive bursts,
two consecutive bursts in preBotzinger.
Now, where the bursts are
a little further apart,
we notice that when we
would've expected a burst
there's one of these burstlets.
Here they're further and further apart
and we have two of the burstlets.
And here we have three,
and they're all coming
when you expect them to come.
So the simplest conclusion here is that
this is what's really
generating the rhythm.
Now, you might say, gee,
this is all negative stuff.
Why don't you tell me something positive?
But you have to understand
that in doing science.
You don't know the answer beforehand
and you go after the usual suspects.
But sometimes we're like the drunk
who's looking under the lamppost.
And you say to the drunk,
what are you looking for?
And the drunk says, I'm
looking for my keys.
And you say, oh, you
dropped your keys there?
He says, no, I dropped them in the bushes,
but the light is here.
And so as scientists, we
go where the light is.
The light looked like it was pacemakers,
it looked like it was inhibition,
it looked like it was bursting.
It's not, so we begin now
to look in other places.
We go look in the bushes.
And when we look in the bushes,
and these burstlets are
generating the rhythm,
what is the mechanism underlying it?
And our current hypothesis,
it's the network.
This is one of the hot
topics now in neuroscience
is how neurons are interacting.
So here's the experiment:
we have this bursting,
it's about 1000 neurons in each burst,
and we said, what
happens if we can trigger
just a few neurons, one, two, three, five?
Would that be enough to initiate a burst?
And then, if we can initiate
the burst, what's the delay?
And with our colleagues in
Paris, Valentina Emiliani,
we were able to do this experiment.
It was very, her technology
was very sophisticated.
And the way it worked is,
here's a blown-up of the
preBotzinger Complex.
And you can see the yellow cells there.
And under a microscope,
we identify the cells.
And then using some chemical magic,
we use a laser to stimulate the cells.
So we can only stimulate one,
two, three, four, five cells.
And what we found was
that, if we stimulate
only three cells at this point,
at some delay, we get a burst.
With only three cells.
If we stimulate three more cells,
we get a burst, and it's
a little bit sooner.
And if we stimulate nine
cells, it's even sooner.
But we only need a few cells to do that.
And what is particularly
intriguing is how long it takes.
Okay, in neural terms, this is like
three-tenths of a second, that's forever.
And what is happening?
So what we think is happening is that
the activity sort of
starts with a few cells
and because of the way the network,
nature builds the network,
the activity doesn't immediately explode,
but it sort of percolates.
And it percolates and it grows slowly
and then all of the sudden explodes.
And we proposed this idea,
which is one of those ideas
which many of our colleagues
thinks are totally crazy,
and Sufi Arshad in the lab
now has experimental data
that's entirely consistent with this idea
and we're very excited
about this possibility
as being critical for
generating breathing rhythm.
So it's the network.
Now we thought we had this done.
We found the engine.
But then we had some
anomalous experiments.
And the mindset was sort of followed
by this article in the New York Times.
And it was A Romance Gone Sour.
"And since the way she breathes,
"exhalation following inhalation,
"has already gotten on your
nerves after 24 hours."
(audience laughing)
We think of breathing as
like inspiration, expiration,
one has to follow the other,
it's like day and night, they
have to follow each other.
Turns out, that's not the case.
So okay, I'm gonna show
you some real data.
So here's a rat breathing.
Down is expiration, up is inspiration.
So it's expiration, inspiration.
And this is expiratory muscle activity.
So it sees the expiratory
muscle activity is very rhythmic
and the inspiration is very rhythmic.
This is normal breathing, quite,
maybe you might say uninteresting.
But if we give this animal fentanyl,
which is an opiate agonist,
watch what happens.
Expiration, inspiration,
expiration, no inspiration.
Expiration, inspiration, now watch this.
Expiration, no inspiration,
expiration, no inspiration,
expiration, inspiration.
And you notice, the
expiration is constant.
So what's going on?
Well, several years of experiments
and we came to the conclusion that
there were two oscillators.
So we have the preBotzinger Complex
and we discovered that
this other oscillator
is sitting nearby in a region
called the paraFacial Nucleus.
It's not in exactly the
same place, but it's nearby.
And we did the following experiment.
We recorded under
conditions where you have
inspiratory activity and
no expiratory activity.
Now, I should say, at rest here,
it's just inspiratory activity for you.
There's no expiratory activity.
You're totally passive at expiration.
It's only when you need
to drive lots of air,
like when you exercise,
that you actively expire.
So it turns out that if we excite
these neurons in the paraFacial region,
and we do this by using this genetic tool
of channelrhodopsin,
we shine a laser light,
and what happens is, we
turn on expiratory activity.
We have inspiration, expiration,
inspiration, expiration,
and then when we turn
the light off, it stops.
So we have lots of data now
that we have these two oscillators
and they normally talk to each other,
they're very tightly coordinated.
The expiratory one is normally turned off,
but we turn it on when
we need to turn it on.
Now, why have separate oscillators?
Well, if you're a
non-mammalian vertebrate,
they done have diaphragms,
they have simple lungs.
In other words, they don't have
70 square meters of lung space.
It's very, very limited,
so they can only pass
a limited amount of oxygen,
they can only support being cold-blooded,
and their brains are a lot smaller.
Our brains are extremely
demanding of oxygen, continuously.
So they can't make inspiratory efforts
because they don't have a diaphragm,
and they have an oscillator that drives
their expiratory-dominated movements.
Now, we evolve into mammals.
Mammals are the only class of vertebrates
that have a diaphragm.
So we now develop these lungs
that can produce a lot of
oxygen, move a lot of oxygen.
And we have a diaphragm,
we have complex lungs,
we can be warm-blooded,
and we have big brains
that are demanding of oxygen all the time.
So powerful inspiratory efforts
are needed and possible.
And our hypothesis is
that a new oscillator,
the preBotzinger Complex,
to drive the diaphragm
that couples to the old
expiratory oscillator.
That's the one in the paraFacial.
So we have this core system
of the preBotzinger Complex
and the parafacial,
they talk to each other,
and then each one drives
either inspiratory muscles
or expiratory muscles.
And so this is the core for
generating breathing movements.
Now, one of the
interesting aspects of this
is that whereas we think brain function
in mammals of all different sizes
sort of acts on the same time scale,
that learning and memory and perception
is the same time scale,
when we look at breathing,
a mouse will breathe up
to 300 times a minute,
a whale that's not diving
will breathe once a minute.
So what is it about the
nervous system that's changed
that you go over a factor of 300
in how the rhythm is generated?
It's not simply the animals are bigger.
There's something going
on, and at some point
we hope to discover what that is.
But I'm going to leave this
as an unsolved problem.
So the summary here is,
we're inspiratory breathers.
Expiration is passive at rest.
And we have two oscillators:
one for inspiration,
one for expiration.
I'm going to talk to you about sighing.
You all know what sighing is.
(sighing)
They're these deep breaths that you take.
The story basically starts with
the widespread use of iron lungs.
When they were first used,
individuals were ventilated
at normal lung volumes
and there was high mortality rates.
Then they decided to ventilate
at slightly higher volumes,
and there's lower mortality.
Then in the '50s, they discovered
what really was necessary
was just to have an
occasional large breath.
Now, why is that?
Well, remember I said there
were 500 million alveoli,
each less than a hundredth
of an inch in diameter?
They're like balloons
that are fluid-lined.
They have a probability of collapsing.
And if you've ever tried
to inflate a wet balloon,
it's very hard.
You've gotta (blowing
out breath), pop it open.
So a normal breath doesn't pop it open.
A sigh does.
So if you sigh every five minutes,
and all of you are sighing
every couple of minutes,
it pops open the alveoli
that have collapsed
during that five minutes.
But if you're prevented from sighing
for an extended period of time,
lots of these alveoli would collapse
and your ability to exchange
oxygen would decline.
And if you're stuck in an
iron lung, you could die.
Now, a colleague of
mine, Victor Yancheski,
was reading that when you're stressed,
your sigh rate goes up.
We know when we're anxious we sigh more.
But it also turns out that
we release these peptides
from a region called the hypothalamus.
And he thought that
maybe these were related.
So bombesin is cheap.
And I said to him, well,
why don't we just buy some
and see what happens?
And we did, and when we inject it
into the preBotzinger
Complex of adult rats,
it increased their sigh rate
from 25 per hour to 250 per hour.
10 times, without changing
their regular breathing pattern.
So we were on to something.
Now we asked, what happens if we kill
the subset of neurons in
the preBotzinger Complex
that have these receptors?
And so here's a control rat.
It's sighing about 25 per minute.
We now add this toxin that only kills
cells that have the
bombesin receptor, BBN.
After three days, the
sigh rate is way down.
The animal's still breathing
normally otherwise.
After five days, the sigh
rate is way, way down.
And then at that point, there
are problems with the lungs
because of all the alveolar collapse.
Now, we have let this data
sit on the shelf for a while.
And through interactions
with Kevin Yackle,
who as an undergraduate at UCLA,
actually heard a lecture of mine,
got interested in breathing
when he went to Stanford,
did some extremely interesting
things about breathing,
discovered that there was
a tiny population of cells,
which you can't see here,
that have one of these,
that express the peptide,
one of the bombesin peptides.
And if you look around
the facial nucleus here,
here's a blowup, you see these red cells.
And if you look throughout
the entire brain,
that's about the only place you find them.
Here's a picture looking
from the ventral surface.
It would be like you were looking
at the brain from this side.
And you can see the cells
and the green dots here.
So they're very localized.
If you inject the peptides
into the preBotzinger Complex,
it turns out the neurons that have
the receptors for these peptides,
that listen to the peptides,
are in preBotzinger Complex.
Here's an animal sighing, these are sighs.
So that's sighing about once per minute,
once per two minutes.
If you inject the peptides,
the sigh rate goes way up.
This is five different rats.
If you inject and you block the receptors,
the sigh rate goes way, way down.
So we've established
a very simple circuit.
This is rather unusual, that
in the brain we can establish
such a simple circuit for a fundamental
and critical behavior
that's ongoing all the time.
We have about 230 neurons here,
while rats have about 230 neurons here
and about 250 neurons there.
And that is driving sighing.
What is the rhythmogenic
mechanism for sighing?
We have no idea.
But we're very interested in finding out.
Now, one nice thing about this paper,
when we published it, it went viral.
And so we had the usual
suspects write about it.
The Guardian wrote
something very straight-up,
the Washington Post wrote
NPR got cute, and a lot of
outlets got very cute about this
because it's a sigh.
But perhaps the thing
I'm most proud of is that
the Onion wrote about it.
It has been found that nerve
cells within the brainstem
regulate sighing to 12 times per hour.
So I really think now we've
sort of sent out our message,
if it's in the Onion.
And it gave me a lot of cred with my sons.
So the summary for this section is,
we must sigh all of the
time, due to a simple circuit
involving the preBotzinger Complex
and the paraFacial Nucleus.
(sighing)
(audience laughing)
Not supposed to laugh,
you're supposed to take a deep breath.
You can laugh, that's okay.
A brief interlude about opiates.
Opiates, lots of people are dying,
it's a big public health problem.
70,000 last year.
Most deaths are due to
depression of breathing.
Can we make a safe formulation
of a prescription opioid?
And the idea is, we found, the
background is, we found that
opiate receptors are in
preBotzinger neurons.
So that makes a logical place that
when someone takes an opioid,
it's not only going to go to places
that are involved in pain,
but also affect breathing
by depressing breathing.
So we can imagine a region
that's important in pain,
like the periaqueductal gray,
the opioid receptors go
there and block pain.
They also go to the
preBotzinger Complex and block,
depress breathing to the point
that someone can asphyxiate.
So is there some way we can block it?
So we have a, we just submitted a grant,
because we have an idea that
was originally demonstrated
or proof of principle in 2003
of a colleague who showed
they can block the actions
here, but not there.
Unfortunately, in the human
trial the drug did not work.
And we think we understand
why and we're hoping to
get money from the NIH to look at this.
So by counteracting opiate actions
in the preBotzinger Complex,
it's possible for safer drugs,
safer for pain management.
Breathing and emotion.
We had a review recently
and this is the cover
that they put on it of a meditating mouse.
And in fact, our interests are
such that we have a grant to
teach mice and rats to
breathe slowly on command
to try and understand how
this is adducing the effects
we know that breathing can
adduce on emotion and pain.
So they're called the
breathe in, breathe out,
the neurocontrol of respiration.
And how can breathing
affect emotional state?
Well, there's a variety of ways,
but I'm just going to mention two.
One is a direct projection
from preBotzinger Complex,
affecting regions involved in emotion.
But what I'm gonna talk to
you now is about a projection,
once again by Kevin Yackle, Mark Krasnow,
and our colleagues up at Stanford,
that identified to go from
the preBotzinger Complex
to a region called locus coeruleus.
Locus coeruleus is a very special region
because from the locus coeruleus,
you have projections going
throughout the entire brain.
And we found neurons in
the preBotzinger Complex
that project here.
And through some molecular
magic, Kevin was able to
kill the small population
of preBotzinger neurons
that projected there,
but left the rest of
the preBotzinger intact.
And what happened is that the animals
seemed to be perfectly normal.
When he looked at it more carefully,
ablating the preBotzinger Cdh neurons
projecting to locus
coeruleus, it slows breathing.
So if you look at the distribution
of breathing frequencies
in a mouse as it grooms, as
it, just during wakefulness,
as it stays still, as it
roams around the cage,
this is the distribution.
After we kill the Cdh9
cells, you could see that
the animal is breathing slower.
Now, associated with the slower breathing,
if you look at the behavior,
and you measure electrical
activity in the brain,
the mice appear calmer.
So we put together the
story that this may be a way
that breathing is
influencing emotional state.
And in this case, the animals are calmer.
Now, this, you can see how,
the profound effects in
preBotzinger Complex.
So here's a side view
of the brain of a rat.
The head is here, the tail is there.
Here's the preBotzinger Complex.
The green is the projections
from the preBotzinger Complex,
which goes to a lot of places.
But what I want you to
look at is this orange,
which is going to locus coeruleus.
And from locus coeruleus,
it goes to the whole brain.
So that's a potential entryway
for breathing to affect the whole brain.
And we're busy investigating this now.
Now, this paper also went viral.
And it had one extremely positive effect.
Shortly after this
appeared, I got a phone call
from a colleague in a
department of psychiatry,
Helen Lavretsky, and Helen
uses breathing exercises
for helping people who
are at risk for dementia
and caretakers for people with dementia
who are under a lot of stress.
And she was looking to put together
a overall research program,
and asked us if we'd be interested.
And of course, we were.
And together with Helen, we are trying to
put together a center to study
the relationship between
breathing and emotion,
where we can get to the
very basic mechanisms
and she can look at, she and
her colleagues can look at
mechanisms involved in the
brain at large in humans.
So we have this core
circuit for breathing.
This core circuit for breathing is
interacting with other movements.
So we have to coordinate
breathing with speech.
In order for me to speak to you,
I have to coordinate
the expiratory airflow
with the fact that in need to take air in
on a regular basis so I don't pass out.
We need to stop breathing when we swallow,
chewing, so there's coordination here.
We also have these, what we
call the ascending inputs
to places like locus coeruleus,
that are gonna coordinate with and affect
emotion, cognitive function,
and sensory function.
And then we have these descending inputs,
which are related to
the emotional expression
of laughing, crying, and so on.
Now I'm gonna end with
another popular quote.
I presume most of you
are familiar with this.
It was written by a Swedish
author, who was educated by
my neuroscientist colleagues in Stockholm.
And I congratulated them because
in this book, he talks about the brain.
And he says, "she had a talent
"for irritating the other employees.
"she became known as 'the
girl with two brain cells'
"one for breathing and
one for standing up."
So just like the European Brain Council,
which mentioned breathing as one of
the most critical things the brain does,
here, Elizabeth Salander
has two brain cells,
and one's for breathing.
But now you know that this is not correct.
She has two for breathing,
one for inspiration,
one for expiration, so she has
at least three brain cells.
(audience laughing)
So in summary, this is
gonna be on the exam.
(audience laughing)
Okay, so, the preBotzinger Complex,
that's the engine for
inspiratory breathing.
It's active before birth because
it has to be working when you're born.
The mechanisms for rhythm
generation are unknown,
but we think the network is very critical.
The paraFacial Nucleus,
it's the engine for
active expiratory breathing.
And I say active, because
normally it's quiescent.
It's silent at rest, because
activated in exercise
and when you make volitional efforts
where you need your expiratory movements.
I talked about sighs.
They're vital for life and it seems to be
a relatively straightforward circuit
that's responsible for doing it.
We don't understand how it's regulated
on a breath by breath
or side by side basis,
but it's, we're actively looking at that.
And then breathing affects emotion.
I will stipulate, yes,
and the mechanisms are
currently being explored.
Now, this work was done in my lab,
but it was done by a large cohort
of extremely talented
and wonderful people.
And I can't thank them individually,
but you'll get to see pictures of
all the people I work with,
who stand behind this work.
And for them I'm eternally grateful,
for their efforts to advance
the topic as much as we did.
With that said, thank you
very much for your attention.
I'll be happy to take some questions.
(audience applauding)
- Professor Feldman, thank
you for such a marvelous talk.
We do have time for questions.
And it's going to be useful,
if you raise your hand,
a person with a microphone,
a roving microphone,
will run towards you.
- [Man] Is yawning a
sighing, a type of sighing,
and what causes that, and
is it indeed contagious?
(laughing)
- This is usually something I reserve for
discussions in bar rooms late at night.
Yawning is another reflex.
We are not entirely sure
what the full benefit is of yawning.
Certainly, we can use that
if our eustachian tubes get closed up,
we can use it to open up the airways.
As far as contagion goes, there may be
a social aspect to yawning.
I'm bored, I wanna get out of here,
and I wanna communicate
that to other people.
Why other people then imitate it,
I can't, I really don't know.
If I had a couple of
beers I might speculate,
but not at this point.
(audience laughing)
- [Man] I have a question over here.
- Jack, Jim Weiss.
- [Man] Beautiful talk.
- Thank you, Jim.
- [Man] Terrestrial mammals, obviously,
mostly breathing is involuntary,
but aquatic mammals,
it seems need much more
of a voluntary mechanism
to control breathing so they don't drown
when they're submerging.
Are there any differences in the circuits
that regulate breathing in them?
- Well, that's a very interesting
question, Jim, thank you.
Diving mammals have a
lot of specializations.
And we actually still have some of them.
It's called a diving reflex.
So if you splash cold water on yourself,
you may initiate the diving reflex.
And what the diving reflex
does is, you stop breathing,
you stop your circulation
from going anywhere
except the two most critical organs:
your heart and your brain.
And if you're a diving whale, it'll go to
your extremely efficient tail muscle.
And the rate of oxygen consumption
then gets reduced tremendously.
Every year we have young
children fall through the ice.
And they could be submerged
for a half an hour and more
and they can survive.
And the reason they survive
is, one, diving reflex,
and two, because they're small,
their surface area to
body volume is so small,
they cool down quickly enough so
that four-minute oxygen that we have
can now last them 30 or 40 minutes,
whereas you and I, if
we went below the water,
we wouldn't cool off fast enough.
So I don't know if that
really answered your question,
but that's as close as I can get.
- [Woman] Thank you.
Here, I'll stand up.
I don't quite know what my question is,
but it's about apnea, sleep apnea.
It seems to be being diagnosed
much, much more frequently these days
and not just in people with CPAPs,
but people who, I don't
know, snore a little.
And I guess I, I'm in the second category,
and I'm just wondering if you,
and we're always told that
there're really dire
consequences of apnea.
Oh, okay, so that's the answer.
(audience laughing)
- Well, I could explain a little bit.
So, you stop breathing,
you're still using oxygen,
so your oxygen levels drop,
depending how long you're not breathing,
your oxygen levels can drop to the point
where they can begin to do damage.
Now remember, you're not
just stopping breathing,
people with sleep apnea, once per night.
It can be as many as 400 times a night,
people stop breathing,
and the only way they
start again is to wake up.
So that has the consequences
of disrupting sleep,
exposing all their cells,
but particularly their brain
to extended periods of low oxygen,
and their blood pressure
can often shoot up
to well over 200 systolic.
So you imagine it happening,
this hundreds of times a night,
and the cumulative effect
over time is just devastating.
Now, the therapy that works are
these positive pressure ventilators.
The problem is, most people hate them
and there's a lot of effort
to try and find alternative mechanisms
that can keep people
ventilating all night.
Did that answer your question?
(woman speaking in background)
Like snoring.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- NIH says that people who
snore have three to five times
the rate of incidence of
strokes and heart attacks.
Snorers, not people
with frank sleep apnea.
So snoring in and of itself is
something that is a matter of concern.
I don't mean to alarm you, but.
- [Woman] Hi.
Since we sometimes
historically have thought of
basic mechanisms in terms
of the male model of human,
I just wonder--
- Excuse me, the?
- [Woman] Sometimes we
think of basic mechanisms
in terms of a male model of human being,
as opposed to both genders.
And I'm just wondering
if your research includes
any potential differences in females.
Because if you're linking the entry points
and neural networks, you know,
I just wonder if you've
seen any differences
between male and female or--
- We haven't, at the level
we've been looking at,
we have not seen any differences.
However, demographically, for sleep apnea
women seem to be
protected until menopause.
And then at menopause, their
rate of sleep apnea rises.
So it's something about the
protective effects, probably,
of hormones that are
reducing the likelihood
that women becomes, have
obstructive sleep apnea.
But as soon as they pass menopause,
their rate of sleep apnea goes up.
(dramatic music)
- [Man] Video copies of
this program are available
for purchase from the UCLA
Instructional Media Library.
Call toll free, 1-877-958-2200.
(chiming music)